o
[Música]
Olá pessoal hoje eu gostaria de fazer
vocês refletirem um pouquinho e para
isso eu tenho uma pergunta para vocês
porque nós damos mais valor depois de
perdermos algo essa pergunta vem me
perseguindo faz um tempo e para vocês
entenderem como eu cheguei nela eu vou
explicar um pouquinho sobre a minha vida
e algumas experiências minhas
e em 2018 eu entrei na minha escola e
nela nós temos o currículo brasileiro e
o currículo alemão eu entrei no
currículo brasileiro e depois de alguns
meses junto com outros alunos eu fui
chamada para estudar no currículo alemão
porque nós temos notas boas eu fiz as
provas Passei mas acabei não podendo ir
porque era meu primeiro ano falando
idioma eles acharam melhor esperar mais
um tempinho isso me deixou muito triste
e em 2019 eu fui chamada novamente para
estar no currículo alemão e dessa vez eu
me esforcei bastante e consegui passar
então 2020 representava para mim essa
superação desse desafio eu tava muito
empolgada e depois de um mês de aula
chegou o coronavírus e nós vamos que ir
para ficar estudando em casa na
sexta-feira Treze foi o meu último dia
normal e acredito que para muitas outras
pessoas também nesse dia eu vi os meus
amigas os professores aprende os
conteúdos e o meu presente geografia até
tinha comentado sobre ficar um mês sem
no aula remota em e eu não acreditei
muito porque isso nunca tinha acontecido
antes e por que que aconteceu agora vou
só aconteceu para minha surpresa e
enfim depois de um mês tem no aula
online eu conheço esse te falta das
minhas amigas porque agora eu não via
praticamente mais ninguém em
2020 acabou
eu ia firmei do Ensino Fundamental 2 e
agora no ensino médio
eu cheguei no meu limite então eu não
aguentava mais viver a mesma rotina que
era acordar as cinco minutos antes de
começar a aula assistir a 5 horas de
aula depois de tarde e Fazer tarefa e de
noite fazer coisas que não era muito
importante coisas fúteis como mídias
sociais
eu cheguei no meu limite Foi numa
sexta-feira quando eu pedi para minha
mãe para a gente sair de carro à noite e
eu consegui sentir me sentir livre
novamente
e eu não queria mais a minha vida
antiga minha vida monótona e
por isso meus pais deixaram então eu e a
minha irmã e meus um dia na escola
presencialmente e nesse dia eu tava
e nada as 5 horas de aula passaram super
rápido
e
vão agora vocês sabem como é que foi a
minha experiência com a quarentena Então
vamos voltar aquela primeira perguntinha
que eu fiz no começo da minha palestra
porque nós vamos mais valor depois de
perdemos e a resposta é porque nós não
demos ou não percebemos o seu real valor
antes de perdemos e agora eles façam uma
nova pergunta como nós podemos dar valor
a algo sem termos que perderam e a
resposta é a gratidão a gratidão é você
reconheceu que tem e ser grato por ter
aquilo é você pegar um problema e
começar a olhar as coisas boas
relacionadas a ele e agradecer por elas
O problema vai ficar pequenininho porque
você vai conseguir pensar em tantas
coisas boas que ele vai fazer quase nem
mais existir e agora preste atenção
o que você considera ruim nesse momento
é porque você ainda não parou para
refletir sobre isso ou seja não
redirecionou o seu pensamento para as
coisas boas para as coisas simples da
vida e esse é o principal propósito da
gratidão
Mas como eu sei a gratidão todos os dias
todos os dias depois de acordar eu
escrevo uma listinha com três itens das
coisas que eu sou grata E isso aconteceu
alguma coisa durante o dia que seja
chata ou que me desmotiva um pouco eu
leio uma dessas vezes tinhas e para mim
isso não me ajuda bastante então eu
aconselho vocês também a fazer
com essas peças claras em minha mente eu
então queria arrumar agora a minha
rotina que como eu falei ela tava sendo
muito ruim para mim que eu não estava
nada feliz com ela
o primeiro então eu fiz uma lista com
todas as coisas que uma nova Fazer e
depois na minha rotina eu escrevi a para
fazer pelo menos um pouquinho
melhor que fosse uma dessas coisas e eu
posso garantir que se você fizer isso
vai melhorar muito o seu dia e enquanto
você estiver fazendo isso ser grato
e com a quarentena eu acabei fiquei
ficando mais tempo em casa e com tudo
isso acabei percebendo os pontos
positivos de ficar em casa então eu
acabei aprendendo a desenhar melhor
quero algo que eu sempre gostei muito de
fazer e esse foi um desenho que eu fiz
eu também passei a ficar mais tempo com
a minha cachorrinha Lua foi que a gente
eu quase não ficava em casa e agora
coloca pandemia eu comecei a ficar mais
tempo com ela e ela virou uma grande
companheira minha
e com a o coronavírus a gente achou
melhor afastar você quer ajudava a gente
em casa e eu comecei ajudar então a
minha mãe a fazer as tarefas de casa e
com isso eu transformei esses momentos
que para muitos não são nada prazerosas
em momentos de conhecimento através dos
meus fones de ouvido ouvindo em números
audiobooks e Esses foram alguns looks
que houve
é algo que eu aprendi com a anemia foi
que a gente não deve focar no que a
gente não pode mudar e sim focar no que
a gente pode mudar ou seja a gente não
pode mudar não pode acabar com a
pandemia Mas a gente pode fazer com que
ela seja menos pesada ou seja fazer o
quilo que a gente ama e ser grato por
fazer aquilo
e por isso eu acredito que a gente deve
valorizar o que tem e com tudo isso que
eu falei vamos se inicializar
muito obrigada a
[Música]